welcome to mama chef a competition where
a professional chef and a mom cook
head-to-head is preparing the best dish
possible featuring one secret ingredient
our first competitor today is mom to
Hera Christie most people don't even
know I have four kids they meet me and
they're like super fun I'm like I know
right my grandmother taught me how to
cook there were no recipe she'd be like
oh you know you put it in a telegram
Emma dated because you know I'm
competing against a Top Chef but you
know what I propose we California babies
nothing intimidates us winning mom
versus chef will make me the best
non-training mom chef in competing
against her is professional chef Dakota
Weiss
I've been cooking professionally for 18
years and I'm the chef partner at
Estrela restaurant and chef partner at
sweets in poky in San Monica growing up
my mom really inspired me to become the
chef that I am kind of forced us to eat
organic and vegetables and everything
out of the garden it's looking I guess
the mom who actually puts four children
daily is a little nerve-racking I have
to kind of dig deep into my inner child
winning this competition would be great
just love for my niece and nephew to
watch it you'd be really excited for it
code us welcome to Hera Chef twice today
you're gonna be competing against each
other trying to create the tastiest dish
possible featuring one secret ingredient
in 30 minutes or less your dishes will
be judged by the panel of judges before
you names Elijah I am 10 years old and I
want to become a pro baseball player or
soccer player
I'm Sydney Sepulveda I'm 12 years old
and when I grew up I would love to be an
actor and singer your final judges me
I'm Andrew I'm 25 years old and when I
grow up I want to be a maple syrup
farmer I think it's time to find out
what our super ingredient is
fill it up for us you guys know what
kind of fish this is different type
something oh no it's it's all one kind
of fish Wow guys this is Sam I have a
lot of experience cooking with salmon
I've burnt plenty of pieces but I've
learned that if you broil it and do it
quickly you come out really good and
tasty on the inside when I eat salmon I
really like it to be a little chewy but
not too chewy I don't like the raw fish
taste all right I cook a lot with salmon
it's one of those fishes that really
goes with a lot of different cuisines so
versatile it's just a really great piece
of fish so guys you're gonna have 30
minutes to prepare your dishes your time
starts now
I'm still kind of conceptualizing my
dish in my head so what I want to do is
a play on a carpaccio which is thinly
sliced salmon with some nice citrus and
avocado thinking I want to do a good
play on maybe introducing some raw fish
and then also kind of doing some cooked
fish as well a lot of people have missed
the boat when it comes to salmon but
they just make lemon dill salt pepper
boring I'm gonna just make this
delicious sweet glaze on top of it I
want to make like that egg roll and
everything will have vegetables in it
can really use these pre-made sauces
before so it should be interesting some
fresh peanut butter
kids like mustard they like hotdog soy
sauce some butter brown sugar
and you're going to know a hero sounds
like you got quite a plan over there I
know they're going to kids like sweet
thing you're sweet they love crunchy see
the care if I see the shredder and I
start shredding my vegetables I want to
incorporate lots of vegetables so it's
healthy but not so many that it's
overpowering I really want to make sure
that my sandwich carpaccio is palatable
I pound it out as thin as I possibly can
maybe this might be a nice introduction
into sushi I see that there's an extra
piece of meat there and I'm like oh
grandpa you kids really like ground beef
let me just throw that in there as well
I put a little Maldon salt on it and
kind of try to build that part of the
dish I'm really nervous you know doing
raw fish for kids is definitely a little
risky so I don't know how this is gonna
go I may have gone too fancy I don't
know I'm so focused I forget to cut the
salmon up because I was just so excited
to like get it in the oven while that's
cooking then I start making my noodles
washed felt kind of things cooking over
there and I don't know anything on this
stove yet chef's you have 15 minutes
left it's even it's hard be a minute
now I'm gonna pull the salmon out of the
marinade and skewer them every kid I
know they all love anything you can eat
off of a stick my news really focus
delicious meal from a mama that loved
them you know mama loves the baby as I
wait for my salmon to come out I then
start preparing my rice paper for the
rolling I think she's making something a
little bit spicy guys yeah I'm just
started getting into spicy food so we're
all like the brat maybe it looks really
good hey Elijah let's go check in on
chef Dakota let's go all right I'll
check on chef to hear it chef Dakota
how's it going good this is good so what
do you make them kind of doing a play on
a cook and what is the saucy ER dipping
the fish this is a
yeah
they say Hera how's it going good good
good just trying to get the last little
bits in here so you've been trying a
couple different ways of making your
dish I've just expanded the whole blow
okay but I think it's gonna be fried too
it doesn't matter will be delicious this
doesn't exactly look like salmon to me
we're definitely salmon in it kids who
don't necessarily eat fish all the time
they can't always be thrown off fighting
me let's just say I've got many cultures
going on at the same time thank you
I'm normally not this messy at home I
got a little sous chefs I gave birth to
five minutes left chefs I realized that
it's time for me to take my salmon out
it looks delicious it's the right type
of flaky but realizing that I forgot to
cut it up I now have to like cut the
salmon right in the middle so it looks
like a big old hunk of meat on top of
the plate but I know it's gonna be
delicious so that won't even matter and
now I take my peanut coconut milk and I
dress that salmon and it looks really
beautiful colors are bright I'm very
happy I'm completely confident I put
some of the salmon on top of that plate
and with literally like five seconds
left or I throw my chives on top of the
plate please explain your dish I have
made a brown sugar honey salmon on top
of rice noodles it's got some green
onions it's got a little bit of ground
beef like a beef vegetable carrot
empanada salmon roll baked things this
looks good looks beautiful I love how
you place the fish on top of the pasta
the fish glaze looks really good
first when I salt like whoa reminds me
of going to the seafood restaurant with
my family my birthday I love how you put
the ground beef with the vegetables
inside of it it brought out so many more
flavors and salmon than I thought there
were you really did surprise me the beef
textures a little bit rough on my like
my gums why did you get a bone there
yeah it's like a really unique
combination of things I don't think it
reminds me of like any specific one
cuisine but I really like it thank you
to here for your dish chef Dakota can
you please describe your dish so what I
did for you is a play on two different
kinds of salmon the first is a carpaccio
style and I glazed it with some soy
sesame vinaigrette a little fresh blood
orange avocado sesame seeds and Thai
basil and then I also did a salmon satay
pop in a classic coconut peanut sauce on
top of a little sautéed shiitake and
some snap peas I love your presentation
but I would have liked the soy sauce to
be even on both sides because I'm very
particular stuck be brave
Wow I can really taste the blood orange
in it the avocado on top that really
added a nice touch to it this dish makes
me like want to run to the beach right
now just make a sand angel I love it I
definitely love the peanut coconut sauce
I think the soy sauce with the sesame
seeds is a little too sour for me for
now I think I'm gonna stick with cookie
salmon it is really just like butter I
mean I this is how I love to eat fish
Thank You chef Dakota for your dish this
is gonna be a hard deliberation I was
just kind of like beginning work and it
did if it was a gorgeous thank you
what do you guys think about Tijeras
dish I would prefer the beef to be a
little bit less chalky I didn't like the
ground beef in the pasta well the only
person that got a bone-in
I didn't get a bone but honestly wanted
to steal every secret that you had and
while I'd like you we should have wind
together someday you're going down as
much as I think you're fabulous I'd be
horribly embarrassed if I lost to you so
I can't go back to my kitchen and tell
all my cooks yeah sorry guys you know so
yeah I mean I want to win this chef
Dakota I've had Sam in a lot of ways
I've never had it as a popsicle yeah
that was really cool it's like what a
contrast yeah well we were like three or
four later just like eat popsicles out
on the porch
I still eat popsicles out of my fortune
I just you know I'm just like this was a
really hard decision but I think we all
know who won let's call the contestants
back out chef Dakota to Hera welcome
back thank you both for coming in today
you both cook some amazing dishes
Tahereh your brown sugar honey
salmon glaze was really amazing chef
Dakota your salmon popsicle stood out
the winner mom versus chef is chef
Dakota I can't believe I lost
there's just no like honestly you know
this is what this girl does so I didn't
want to hurt her too bad so I probably
held back just a little bit quite the
honor it really is honestly I know kids
palates can be very finicky cooking for
my niece and nephews so this is good and
I'm really excited to tell my sister and
anything that being this is awesome
thank you both for coming in and cooking
some amazing food for us this has been
mom versus chef you guys want for
dessert fish pasta Paul how about we
just stick with like chocolate cake is
ready
oh yes